enfiler des gants prenez une pioche et
ajoutez beaucoup de motivation vous
obtenez le cocktail parfait pour la
création d'une microforée au quartier de
la joue à Maurepas les habitants ont été
invités à planter 1900 arbré arbustes
sur 650 mètres carrés
on a creusé ensuite on a essayé d'un peu
de on a mis la plante on a remis un peu
de terre et on a ramolli la terre et on
a mis une espèce de petit copeau de bois
autour au total 250 personnes ont
répondu présentes sur la journée une
manière pour les habitants de contribuer
à la vie de leur quartier tout en
faisant un geste pour l'environnement on
a un peu d'estime en se disant on va on
va aider à notre échelle à planter des
arbres même si c'est pas grand chose
c'est c'est toujours mieux que que de ne
rien faire pour nous c'est surtout
investir dans notre quartier un endroit
un peu plus beau pour nos balades
quotidiens et pour les plus petits
d'être sensibilisés dès leur plus jeune
âge pour que dans 20 ans il est plus
d'arbres et que les se soient plus
écologique c'est la vraie des animaux
ça freine le réchauffement climatique
mon repas est la deuxième ville de 50
ans en Yvelines à s'engager dans cette
démarche après plaisir objectif à terme
recréer un microsystème dans un milieu
urbain l'objectif c'est de créer des
îlots de fraîcheur à terme cette
microforêt va favoriser justement la
biodiversité d'ici 3 à 5 ans et cette
microfora et après sera impénétrable
d'ici une vingtaine d'années rendez-vous
dans quelques années pour les premiers
résultats la ville est déjà à la
recherche d'un second site pour y
implanter une nouvelle microforée